(techno music)
("Jock Box" by The Skinny Boys)
- This is a poster.
That's a poster.
- [Jillian] Wow.
- [Adam] Borat holding carrots.
I don't understand.
- That is Montez's Hitler.
What are you talking about?
- Is it?
- You need to take
that down right now.
- Didi doesn't get it.
- Handle it.
- Montez wants us all
on a juice cleanse.
More like Jews cleanse,
I am right, Didi?
All the Jewish
people out of here?
You don't want that.
Vote for me, I'll shop for you.
- Wait, what was that?
- I'll shop for you.
- I like that.
See what I did?
Threw a little sarcasm
on it, that's something
that you don't understand.
- So that means he
doesn't like it.
I do like it.
- You do like it?
- I think it's good.
- Oh, I do, though.
I guess I don't
understand how it works.
- [Anders] Clearly.
- I saw we take the break room,
and we healthify this bitch.
- We all know I can use it.
Daddy loves his carbs.
(Didi laughing)
- I'm doing Dick in a Box.
I might, like, do
all that other stuff
after we're done having sex, but
there might not be enough time.
Cause that's how much
sex I'm gonna have.
- [Jillian] Okay.
- I'm just glad I didn't
sell all these suits that
Jet Set left me in his will.
Rest in peace, Jet Set!
- Miss you!
- You can kinda hear him
in the vents or something.
- It's my dick.
It's gonna be mine, all right?
And you're asking me to
sand blast your cock?
- You know what, bud?
If you want my dick,
then there are rules and
this is one of them.
You don't wash it!
- It looked like somethin
from Castle Graceshott.
- No, and that's another thing.
You do not shave it.
- Oh, now you're gonna
tell me how to style it?
- [Karl] That's right!
- I noticed it's pierced,
and I'm taking that out.
- No, you're not taking it out.
No, I got that
piercing when I was 12.
- Saw your dick.
It's
horrendous.
Yeah, no.
- Very weird.
- It's very gray.
- Karl, your penis is weird.
It's got an elbow, and it
looks like a dried-out catfish.
- Well, yeah, I mean,
it's got a crook.
It's not for everyone.
- Your shaft is hairy as well,
which is weird.
It's like a stranded
puppy at the pound.
Maybe it was drowned,
saved, bite marks.
- So, like,
whassup with those
kissing lessons?
- Are you talking to me?
- Stop it, dude.
- Oh, he wants to
kiss one of you guys.
(curly-haired woman laughs)
- Guys, I'm trapped
in the closet.
You gotta get me
out of here fast.
- Okay, well, plans
are hard to think of,
so it might take us a minute.
(soft electronic music)
Blake?
If you are trapped in a
closet, and that means
that you're a gay
dude and you're afraid
to come out of the
closet, I want you to know
that I still love you.
- I'm not gay.
- When you say you've been
taking steroids, how many?
58.
- Was feelin so strong
until my heart popped.
You know I had six uncles
that died of heart attacks?
- I did not.
That's not in here.
- That's a lie.
I think that's a lie.
It might only be two.
- What am I writing
down, two or six?
- Write down three.
("Jock Box" by The Skinny Boys)